my friends yes i was having a
conversation with a good friend of mine
and they uh i was i was mentioning this
they said like everybody donate to joe
biden
and i responded with i will never vote
for someone from the obama
administration
fool me once you know fool me twice yeah
um but pro war so no dice
and i i ultimately you know they there
was some conversation about will they
swap out
joe biden with somebody else at this
point i don't think so i think it's it's
biden harris
we're in the long harris is clearly
the the front runner the tickets
inverted it's a silly game they're
playing yeah
but you know maybe like but before this
happened it was like maybe cuomo
and i ultimately said at this point i'm
likely going to be voting for trump
and my friend was like not happy with it
like
i i trust you i've known you and and i
assume you've you've researched
this and i said listen man in california
they voted to repeal civil rights law
right i understand if you're a white
liberal who grew up in a wealthy suburb
or middle class suburb
you don't have those stories in your
life from your family
about what it means to have accomplished
civil rights i remember that photo of
you've seen the photo of bernie sanders
being arrested during the civil rights
movement yeah
it's a famous photo and everyone cheers
for bernie for that the only problem is
these people are trying to walk the
clock turn the clock back they don't
support bernie's ideas from when he when
he fought for this
yep that meant a lot to me when i saw
that photo of bernie mcmahon here's a
guy who actually fought for civil rights
but okay so this kind of kind of gets me
too because if you care about your
friend
and you know that your friend is for
example mixed race
and has a history of growing up in a
mixed race household wouldn't you be
like you know what
i'm going to put myself in your shoes
and try to understand where you're
coming from and be like
maybe you're right well my friends are
into this this is crazy good that's
great
yeah so that's what i'm saying you know
like these are people i've known my
whole life and they literally said
i trust that you've done your research
and you know what you're talking about
but you know wow and then we had some
you know minor private conversation and
complete disagreement but i just said
you know do you know what it's like when
you have
a democratic base in this country that
has adopted a cult
like ideology based on literal racism
what it means to my family and like what
we see when they when they literally
voted to do this
in california i'm like all of a sudden
i'm i'm like there are people i've known
who you know
i want to be vague enough about it but
people in my extended family
who are immediate just like they
immediately saw that they went it's
trump it is
it's like we've lived through this yeah
not again lived through it nope
sorry and i think when you when it's
really easy it's really easy for these
leftists
to say things like we're going to do
affirmative action
and and it's going to be good for
everybody yes
there are some races that are probably
going it's good for me
you know if you're if you're black in
this country they they're telling you
they'll benefit you they'll give you
more access if you're latino
if you're white or asian however you
know they're saying the opposite
but more importantly what if you're a
mix
yeah the smallest minority for example
and all of a sudden now
everything they're proposing is like
you go to the gutter right no matter
what because
especially if you come from a family
like mine which brings me to
actual good news yeah good news
everybody yes
yale illegally discriminates against
white and asian students justice
department says
boom yale university's undergraduate
admission process illegally
discriminates against white and asian
students
a two-year investigation into the ivy
league school found that race is the
determinant determinative factor
in hundreds of admissions uh each year
in violation of title vi
of the civil rights act of 1964 the doj
said i'm clapping a yale spokeswoman
responded
we are proud of yale's admission
practices and we will not change them on
the basis of such a meritless
hasty accusation she's proud of being
racist two-year investigation
is not a hasty accusation when did bill
barr come into play
oh a year and a half ago was what was
this years ago
i don't care i don't care if this is the
doj and he's running the doj right
correct yeah
i like bill barr yep look man i i
i think affirmative action is
it's it's it's it's like a candy
it's a it's bait we're gonna we're gonna
do these things for you i'll tell you
what
unit i see from several polls over the
past you know year
trump really is doing well among african
americans yeah that's been consistent
yeah it has been and there's polls from
like emerson
which found 30 or so percent shocking
numbers
i think like rasmussen has found
shocking numbers consistently
and rasmussen was responsible nailed it
for the popular vote in 2016 they could
be wrong but could they be this
wrong this often maybe to be fair maybe
but it's is a big difference between
polling non-college-educated
white people which they can't do and
polling
you know uh african-americans in this
country right i
i feel like this is probably real
i mean i'm i'm seeing these viral tweets
where they're like trump is going to get
a a an and historic
and historic they're just assuming
you'll drop the h a little bit yeah and
historic
uh percentage of the black community to
vote for him yeah
i don't know but i've seen i've seen
posts everybody wants to tell you
that it's true or it's not true i don't
know
what i will tell you is it certainly
seems like the democrats are operating
as though it's true
yep the panic mm-hmm the the the um
every big brand endorsing black lives
matter and pushing these things
all the racial components i think i
seriously think that the focus on race
right now is because of the fact that
trump is doing well with him
and i'm just reminded of the super like
i forget what percent it was do you
remember what the black unemployment was
that before coronavirus no but it was
like historically low
incredibly low it was the lowest it'd
been in i think 50 years
and i remember i remember being like how
how's the left gonna respond to this
apparently it's by pulling out all the
stops and going burning down
cities burning everything down and just
destroying the economy
i don't i we've seen the polls from
gallup and it like they're
they're behind every step of the way but
i i wonder if the whole
intersectionality bit that they're
embracing is because they think it will
be popular among minority groups
to to act like right right i mean
especially if you're
asian surprisingly i've seen polls
showing that
while donald trump is doing tremendously
well among uh
the black community and the latino
community not like he's not beating the
democrats right
still the majority's way better than
republicans right
historically have done yes right but
asians still like
democrats yeah interestingly and i found
that interesting
there's a couple other things like maybe
it's because they're lumping asians with
every other race on these polls when
they put
other thanks thanks thanks guys geez
that you can't get an accurate portrayal
of it but it seems like
you know their their play isn't isn't
going to work
i think i tell you what man you've got
i think people i think on average people
want to know the path of success
and if you give someone a safe clear and
path to success they take it
right and when you back them into a
corner give them no options they do what
they have to do to survive
and i think these democrat-run cities
are collapsing they've become chaotic
and it is it is it is hurting
marginalized groups
more than ever 100 yeah let me tell you
let me i told you my story about the
t-shirts
when i was younger i think i may have
mentioned it in the store on the show
before
no this doesn't sound familiar okay yeah
tell me a story and then i want to show
you some racism from the
mainstream media but uh i grew up on the
south side of chicago yeah very very
mixed
there was this black dude who was
mocking the gang bangers and
other people like i knew who were
selling drugs and he basically said
you can sell t-shirts man and make more
money and you don't go to jail
so why would you sling dope that's the
stupidest thing ever
and like we were hanging out a park and
people asked them like
how do you sell t-shirts like you mean
like on the highway he's like listen
listen listen
go find a venue right you got these you
got these cafes you got these venues
you they they have these bands these
bands will play
and they got no merch so you you look at
who's about to play
you call them up and say here's what i'm
going to do i'm going to make t-shirts
i'm going to bring them
and i'm going to give you 20 of
everything i sell and the band say
okay and he's like i tell you what i do
he's like i put in a couple hundred
bucks
i get a bunch of like like not even the
best shirts you know
screen printed i bring them to the venue
i work one day a week i make like two
grand a week
what and everybody was like whoa these
people on the south side were told like
you got to join a gang you got to sell
drugs this is how you make money nobody
wants to work at mcdonald's and this guy
was like t-shirts bro
that is fantastic they just needed
someone to tell them how to do it
trump is doing that yeah man trump is
saying here's a job
here's a factory this is for you this is
for your community it's going to help
you succeed and people are saying thank
you i wanted this
okay so that must be why his approval
rating is so high because people want
to feel like talking about the news
being so bad all the time and before
someone clips it i mean literally all
races
they're like there are more poor white
people in this country and they're being
given a chance and an opportunity the
same
right it is the opioid crisis is
predominantly affecting i think
white people white people and so so i
think why
we're seeing such support from latinos
and from
this is this is interesting trump's
losing support among white people
and it's probably because they're far
left intersectionalists yeah
and then meanwhile minorities are like i
like being you know
like i'm like they're regular like this
this country you'll find
is why i can't stand racism regular
people
we all tend to want the same things yeah
we we want to we want to uh you know
work a good day's work earn our keep
feed your kids
feed your kids that's it that's what you
want to feel accomplished exactly
i did this i'm doing the right thing
yeah and i think
i think trump helped create that covid
is destroying that i think people of
every race across the spectrum they want
to feel a sense of hope
and i think i really think that that is
something that donald trump has done
really well with for all his other
shortcomings i
i have some issues with him like i said
i don't really like what he's done with
the deficit
but again i think that that is just
stamp collecting like tim says
if if you can give people that sense
that there is something to be hopeful
about
that's amazing like that is actually
caring about
what american people want that's
significant i think about
surviving versus succeeding yeah and i
think people don't want to just survive
they want to succeed
in order to succeed you have to be shown
a path
a light at the end of the tunnel when
people lose hope then they're just
surviving and survival can be dangerous
it can be
crime and poverty breeds crime yeah
it's not always that these criminals are
just evil who want to steal things
i know aoc got dragged a lot for for her
ignorantly uh suggesting that murder was
overbred it wasn't
well but but to be to be fair
if if i try to actually fix her
statement
petty crime is actually way down yeah
she was wrong
murder is way up chi was wrong but there
is
a lot of crime based on survival yeah
but if you can give someone a job at a
say
meat processing plant when when when uh
trump had federal law enforcement
arrest non-citizen workers i'm being
diplomatic i understand i know
uh and these people got deported we saw
a bunch of
a bunch of people um people yeah local
americans
immediately took the job and it was
people of all races and they were asked
about it
and they said this pays better than
mcdonald's yeah so why were they
bringing in
you know non-citizen labor to do the job
it makes you wonder
well trump it was part of what he was
doing that opened up these jobs to
people
who really just wanted an honest good
day's work
and they struggle to find it so trump
lowers unemployment
they they it this makes it you know what
you know what's crazy is
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
about trump and it's his character that
really sets him back
there were things he did early on that
he didn't know what he was doing i think
you know john bolton is an easy exam
he's an
easy example he's improved greatly
he's calmed a lot he's calmed down a bit
and
he still has he's still a man of bad
moral character
and i know some people are going to be
like what is that supposed to mean tim
come on like
what he's like cheated on his wife yeah
so he cheated on his wife and i
i i don't know people talk about how
he's not like the type of person that
you'd have over for dinner but you could
vote for him and i'm like
fine i don't need you to be my best
friend i need you to follow through on
some of this stuff
and and in fact i think that the i the
concept of giving the american people
hope
is a mark of character to me that marks
out a lot of his
other shortcomings that's huge that's a
really big deal
he's lose he loses women because of it
because of the
the way he's like you know it's funny to
see people laugh when he made fun of
rosie o'donnell
but this is what contributes to him
losing a lot of female voters
i'll tell you what though trump tweeted
out recently he's like the suburban
housewife is going to vote for me
because she wants safety
he might be right i think so i think the
riots were a big mistake and democrats
should have should have denounced it
yeah now they want to bring on kamala as
though she's going to be their law and
order savior and it's like no no i'm
sorry
if you've got riots and you respond with
a despot
you've created two extremes that i don't
want anything to do with
okay peaceful protest is fine riots are
bad
kama locking up people in very crazy and
cringy and scary ways
not okay two things can be bad at once
apparently
like you you've just adopted two
authoritarian standpoints on this great
let me show you let me show you this
tweet this is an eye roll
oh boy julia how do you pronounce her
name
yeah is that really it's italian i'm
just kind of making it up here's the
story
washington post justice department
accuses yale of illegal bias against
white
asian americans and she says bill barr
is fighting hard for white folks
what wait but what she completely
ignored they don't
exist and i don't understand that they
don't
care this is why i said i don't believe
that
the the liberals of this country have a
high care marker in their moral
foundations yeah
i care about white people and asian
people i care about black people and
and latino people and i want everyone to
have a laugh and hang out and play music
together
i don't get it you know what man i'm i
am not conservative
and as much as it's crazy how the left
tries to frame it
and i think it really easily comes down
to like i mean for one abortion issues
like i'm very clearly liberal on so many
of these issues
that have been historically aligned with
democrats but the left has just
jumped off the cliff and i say i say it
enough but it's it's true
and so now when i see people like
julia we we know you're ignoring that
asians exist
like this was the primary target of
these universities because the largest
proportion of people who were going
there were asian
yeah and guess what the best part is
asian doesn't just
mean one race these people are so racist
that is incredibly racist okay let's try
let's play a game okay
filipinos are asian chinese people are
asian
indians are asian oh yeah malaysians
and i mean you can some people would say
pacific islander for some countries but
no like it is
it is an eclectic diverse region
that what people don't realize when it
comes to
how they actually chart whether you're
asian or not indian immigrants
are one of the highest proportions of
people who get into these schools
and they assume it's all like you know
asian is in chinese or something that's
their that's that's that's
that's what they see in their head and
you get things like joe biden you know
when he said the average
person can't tell the difference between
you know someone from korea or china or
something i can't i can't belie i'm like
are you have you ever seen these people
dude yeah what are you talking about
to me joe biden erasing like the
presence of indian people
and indonesian people and filipino
people is kind of shocking
because i would never do that and they
call me racist all day and night but i
actually care about asian people going
to yale
you know significant it it really annoys
me
to like beat the dead horse that we know
the democrats have adopted racism as a
strategy to
try and win and i wonder if what they're
thinking is
racists exist in all races right that
you know
i mean i know this personally from
visiting south korea and from having
korean family they're raised they're
really racist yeah like they're not just
racist against other
other you know asian countries like
they're racist against
everybody it brings it unites us we're
all just kind of racist
it's it is changing so i visited i
visited south korea and
it's it's really fascinating i've been
told outright by many
people who are like probably gen xer
boomer that if i
actually grew up there or tried to live
there i'd be treated like a second-class
citizen
i'm not i i understand you know i'm
mostly white and all this stuff
but i have you know family history in
seoul and in some other towns
and they were like no way they're like
ethno-supremacists it's changing with
the younger generations
so i don't know i don't want to pretend
like i know everything about the country
because i've only visited it
uh i've only been there i think one time
and i didn't spend an extended amount of
time there and even
you know my mom is born and raised in
america but that i've been told this by
uh regional experts journalists and when
i went there like they're
they're they're like super racist and
japan is too
i have heard that yeah yeah and so we
end up with uh this story i had it a
million times because
this to me california proposition 16
repeal prop 209 affirmative action
amendment was like
i didn't believe it i didn't believe it
i didn't know it existed
until they'd already voted on it and
then it was tucker carlson
who brought it up and he straight up
said they voted to repeal
civil rights legislation from their
constitution in california and i went
there's no way that's true
there's no joke but i don't i i don't
think tucker carlson's a liar
he does his homework i might disagree
he's had some questionable
moments like when it came to pot
legalization and there was um
i mean what was it he had he had
somebody on i can't remember
there's been a few moments where i'm
like come on but for the most part i
think he's the best guy on tv
i really do yeah and and i think even if
you disagree with him he's a general
populist and it's crazy how i say this
and also on the left screams and they
take a screen grab of it they're like
tim is praising tucker carlson tucker
carlson's far right blah blah blah
he's not not really he's not do you see
that exchange between him and hannity
when he was like companies profiting off
of a pandemic it was so weird to me
i was like i kind of knew that about
sean hannity although i have
i have independently limited my exposure
to sean hannity as much as possible for
obvious reasons but seeing that exchange
between him and tucker was like
oh my gosh sucker's face oh because
because
the the tre there's like transferring
the show and handy hannity goes these
are fox news personnel as most you
probably know that
hannity is like if a business wants to
provide a service and they make good
you know money off it when so be it and
then tucker did the brow thing yeah it
was like
looks at the camera thing the labrador
thing yeah
yeah this is what you can show your
friends california prop 16
repeal proposition 209 affirmative
action amendment 2020.
they say a yes vote supports the
constitutional amendment to repeal
provision 209 which says the state
cannot discriminate against
or grant preferential preferential
treatment to persons on the basis of
race
sex color ethnicity or national origin
in public employment
public education and public contracting
to be very very clear
it's specifically about state level okay
public
employment education and contracting
they call it the affirmative action
amendment
i believe that is unfair because all it
does is strike this language
that stops the state from discriminating
however
repealing it would allow them to do
affirmative action
me i don't care i don't care what you
call it i don't care what you think it's
going to do for you
when i like this right here should be
more than enough for anybody to be alike
how is this literally a thing yeah do
they
listen we recently had a supreme court
ruling saying that sex
meant gender identity and orientation
will that
impact what this legislation means now
better believe it so does that mean that
in california
if they repeal this there can be a
public job announcement saying
you know straight white men only of
course and it would be legal
yeah i can't i show this to my friends
they don't know it exists
and what's going to happen is come
november it's going to be on the
referendum it's going to be on the
there's going to be a referendum for it
and then people are going to be like oh
affirmative action
yep and there it is they say california
is a few a few years away from
they're a few years ahead of three years
ahead of us yeah yeah and i found this
to be true
i mean also unfortunately they banned
uber
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you